Spurs calves heat clippers they're all
just spokes on a wheel
this one's on top then that one's on top
and on and on it spins we are not going
to stop the wheel we're going to break
the wheel
when were we talking about Azure dawg
hey hey you
you must be the new guy right Jason
Thompson pleasure
my name's draymond of Saginaw let me
introduce you to some of the guys we got
here mole house pockets I would as a
baboso to Brazilian blur we're going to
be championship again and a big guy over
there that's bogey till Mountain High
kangaroo Vegemite Savin on the barbie I
ain't you newest arm coach Walton first
lesson never drinks from me cook bars
over there made that mistake and they'll
never drink again why don't we get Jason
a real drink Brandon get him what he
needs get what you need warriors our new
season is upon us and winter is coming
we we get winter in the Bay Area no it's
actually quite nice a lot of last year
we won 67 games
we win a thousand games or Darwin
against weight that would only be one
game a year those men down there they're
hungry they're hungry for our rings but
we've got to be hungrier than them we've
got to be crazier I saw six warriors we
will hold this war we will hold this
title but we will hold my deck
hello guys that David Lee can let me out
I brought you pull a